qué significa la gravedad específica la
gravedad específica de un objeto es la
densidad de ese objeto dividida entre la
densidad del agua la densidad del agua
es 1000 kilogramos por metro cúbico por
ejemplo la densidad del oro es de 19 mil
300 kilogramos por metro cúbico por lo
que la gravedad específica del oro es 19
mil 300 kilogramos / metro cúbico sobre
1000 kilogramos / metro cúbico que es
igual a 19.3 la densidad de la casa es
de 1.400 kilogramos por metro cúbico por
lo que su gravedad específica es 1.400
kilogramos por metro cúbico entre mil
kilogramos por metro cúbico o sea 1.4
noten que la gravedad específica no
tiene unidades ya que es la proporción
de una densidad entre otra por lo que
las unidades se cancelan y por qué nos
interesa definir algo llamado gravedad
específica
bueno una cosa genial de la gravedad
específica es que para algo que flota la
gravedad específica nos indica la
fracción del objeto que está sumergida o
que estará por debajo del agua mientras
flote por ejemplo digamos que tenemos un
cubo de madera con una gravedad
específica de 0.2 este va a flotar en el
agua y ya que su densidad específica es
de punto 2 el 20% del volumen total de
este cubo va a estar sumergida por
debajo del agua mientras flote si el
cubo de madera tuviera una gravedad
específica de 0.6 entonces el 60% de
este cubo va a estar por debajo del agua
el hielo tiene una densidad de 920
kilogramos por metro cúbico lo que
quiere decir que el hielo tiene una
gravedad específica de 0.92 y es por eso
que el 92 por ciento de una es ver que
se va a encontrar por debajo de la
superficie del agua pero qué pasaría si
usamos un cubo que tiene una densidad de
2.700 kilogramos por metro cúbico la
gravedad específica sería de 2 punto
lo que significa que el 270 por ciento
de este cubo va a estar por debajo del
agua pero no podemos tener más del 100
por ciento de algo bajo el agua aún
cuando el objeto se hunda la cantidad
máxima que va a estar sumergida va a ser
el 100 por ciento del objeto así que si
la gravedad específica de un objeto es
mayor que 1 ese objeto se va a hundir al
menos si lo soltamos en agua y tendrá
exactamente el 100 por ciento de su
volumen sumergido en el agua normalmente
cuando las personas se refieren a la
gravedad específica se refieren a la
densidad del objeto dividida entre la
densidad del agua pero algunas veces nos
es útil definir la gravedad específica
con respecto a un líquido que sea
diferente del agua por ejemplo si
tuviéramos madera con una densidad de
638 kilogramos por metro cúbico flotaría
en aceite ya que la densidad del aceite
es de 850 kilogramos por metro cúbico y
ahora sí podríamos encontrar la
proporción de esta madera que estaría
por debajo de la superficie
este líquido simplemente tenemos que
usar la densidad del aceite en lugar de
la densidad del agua en la fórmula de la
gravedad especifica si lo hacemos nos
daremos cuenta que la madera va a flotar
en este aceite con un 75 por ciento de
su volumen sumergido en el aceite